so we just got some feedback from Jeremy
about our appt one of the things I
wanted you to note about this is that he
didn't have trouble with some of the
things that we had trouble with in the
first iteration of user feedback he had
no trouble finding the check boxes there
wasn't any confusion around task versus
event and he seemed able to navigate
around the app pretty well however there
were a couple of things that we noticed
that are a little bit wrong with the app
still Jeremy wanted to actually input
his data into the app and Jeremy noticed
there were a lot of extra things in the
app that maybe weren't tied to the core
aspects that I was asking him about
these are things that will look into in
the future and as we continue to iterate
are things that you would solve